podcast in the dunya the three muslims
today
i am so dead again
like i was yesterday two days in a row
two days i mean two weeks
two weeks right
yeah they're seeing it after one week
yeah yeah i'm dead speaking of uh not
mentally being here
uh unfortunately there's a lot of people
that aren't mentally here no i'm just
playing this game
we just started man unfortunately you
know i just want to start off with
saying this i want to be real and as
authentic as possible bro
i told you guys about this especially on
hill
i was pretty i was pretty upset a few
nights ago
i just i couldn't sleep i don't know if
i had too much sugar or something but i
went i lied down and i started getting
these like intrusive thoughts
you know i'm like i'm going to hit 40
and my cats are going to be dead
you know
one day and that's why i think i'm like
my family's going to be dead i'm going
to be dead
you know i don't think like all the
people who have lost their families
people who lost their own lives who died
and i was found a lot and then some
people are going to wake up to a really
harsh reality you know it just put me in
this huge state of depression you know i
went
uh literally crying to my sister's room
and crying and my brother came in as
well i was crying and hunted that they
actually started praying after that
little moment because i was just very
honest with them
alhamdulillah it was very beautiful to
see that but
the next night i felt something very
similar and this time i kind of told
myself something that's kind of like it
sounds normal to think
but when you tell yourself that when
you're in such a such a sad state and by
the way this is not any
advice we're not professionals right
you're not psychologists psychiatrists
whatever we're not
professionals by any means so you know
oh we we're professional bro we're
professionals we're just unlicensed this
guy's
try boy viewer discretion is advised
please
consult the professionals the licensed
professionals but it's also a
professional
before you take our advice
but the the thing that i told myself uh
and i think i told you guys this last
night was that it's okay to be sad like
it's normal to be sad because i think
with being sad there's also this like
notion the stigma nowadays that you
shouldn't be sad that it's weird to be
sad or wrong that kind of adds a level
of cognitive dissonance to the fact that
you feel sad you also feel like you
shouldn't be feeling sad which adds
another level to it and after that i
have to tell myself like it's okay to be
sad just live life sad live in this
moment sad sleep sad wake up sad like
like it sucks to be sad but it's not
doesn't mean it's not normal right so
that that really helped me personally
well that's like reminding me of like
back in the day when i was like real
into
the uh new age spirituality
that's a big thing that they would like
talk about is like when you feel
something don't try to run away from it
because if you feel happy do you run
away from being happy no no right like
you try to actually
hold on to that like as long as possible
but when you actually feel sad like you
said you know we try to run away from it
we try to distract ourselves because we
don't want to feel it doesn't feel good
but
you said it best
we it's
like it's all right it's all right to be
in that state yeah you know and like i
don't know if y'all have experience i
know you did obviously because you just
said you did yeah but like usually like
if you let yourself feel it
it goes by a lot quicker yeah then like
if you try to distract yourself maybe
like be on your phone
maybe you play call of duty or watch
anime or something like that or hang out
with your friends or your your
significant other well we don't have
significant others yet so
i think this reminds me of what i was
talking about last night with anha
before we went to sleep
and it was about how many people just
take the time to meditate bro and just
take the time to just be okay with their
thoughts and i was i was actually
telling on her about you know it's been
a while since i meditated properly and
and really not i don't want to say hi at
the time because that's such an excuse
bro it's so cringe but made the time to
sit down with my thoughts and silence
for just a few minutes
yes we make time for salah and
everything else but just having time
either before salah or after even during
salah bro how many how many people just
take the time to like process everything
they're going through
we don't and because we don't we have to
deal with this
later on yeah yeah
yeah
i wanted to quickly say something about
what rami said about how you know you
felt sad and you felt this you feel that
and what i'm trying to say is we live in
a world today where feelings are
deemed as abnormal i don't know if i'm
the only one that feels that but if
you're angry there's something wrong
with you
if you're tired there's something wrong
with you this yeah there's levels to it
but genuinely just feeling some type of
way
transitionally is okay it makes you
human
you know thinking there's something
wrong with you thinking this is a
disorder thinking this is something you
identify with that's that's a whole
different ballgame bro especially for
men i was going to say that as well yeah
you were thinking the same thing yeah
100
because bro like we live in that time
man whereas like as men i mean i don't
know about y'all but when i was a kid
like i was put down for having emotions
really bro like my grandma if i was like
crying or something my grandma would
just smack me upside the head why
because she's like quit being a girl
yeah bro and like i remember when um
my mom she was with this other man he
was basically like my stepdad told you
guys about this
dude like this man anytime that i showed
any little hint of emotion he would call
me out real quick and be like yo stop
being a man stop being an itch
a bick yeah stop being a big
or he would say stop being a pansy oh
hey bro you say so many things and it's
like bro for the longest time i thought
it was um i thought it was not good for
men to show emotion
right but it's like the more that i came
into islam i'm like realizing ah
it's not about not showing emotion
it's about understanding your emotion
and processing your emotion and
like we talked about if you have an
emotion you can use it or it will use
you
yeah right yeah well why don't you
explain a little more of what that means
to the viewers yeah so
like
for instance let's say you get into a
uh you know argument with someone
right you get heated you get really
angry like this anger could clearly
control you
and you could maybe say something that
you didn't want to say or act in a
certain way that of which maybe later on
you look back and you're like
um
i could have
could have handled that better you know
and like
you basically do yourself dirty at that
point
and um if you were to have noticed that
anger been able to just breathe relax
allow the anger to be there but then
use that anger to
basically be more assertive and very
clear and cut to the point and like
drive your point home
that would have been a lot better for
you
than to let that emotion control you and
then i was telling rami about this too
like if you ever think back to your life
to the time where
you
responded
from an emotional place versus when you
responded from a grounded place anytime
you responded from an emotional place
kind of sound like like a little kid
yeah you know like a kid just like being
emotional or going through like a temper
tantrum or something yeah yeah yeah but
then when you come from a granite place
it's like
you sound like a man you sound proper
you know yeah
but there are generally people that have
unresolved childhood trauma bro in
conflict
so i you know i do want to jump into
that but i want to you know see if rami
has anything to say to one who said
those four
uh just uh to kind of reiterate not
reiterate but give an example
um i'm not gonna give any specifics but
there was one guy recently i shouldn't
even say guy but you know i was gonna
try and leave everything out even gender
but i slipped up already so there's one
guy at work uh long story short he was
upset about something when he was
complaining to me about it most people
like listen man we agreed to this this
is going on and we're not getting
whatever right they're unhappy it's
clear it's obvious they want a refund
sometimes things happen in life
this guy when he was complaining bro i
thought he was going to cry he's like i
honestly felt like i'm talking to like
either i'm like either this guy is my
wife or he's a kid like other no one
else should be talking to me like that
yeah and you have neither yeah
bro now imagine this guy would have like
hey
hey it's only for now yes it's going
from there
but imagine this guy would have like
came at you properly and i've been like
look
this is what i was promised
this is what i'm not getting
this is what i want
and if i don't get this and this is this
and this is that like if you would have
came to you real proper and like you
were gonna look like
i don't have the answers for you like
okay
put me in connection with someone who
does have these answers i'm pretty sure
if ana will ask anyone for a refund i
don't care what it is for they're gonna
give you that refund bro nah actually
bro i i gotta i gotta vent a little bit
here man i'm trying to take french
lessons and you guys know the um
actually i won't say the app because i
don't want to like have like any bad
connotations yeah but like i had paid
for rosetta stone
i had paid for a certain amount of like
lessons
and i pay for it with a certain
individual
and um
just the individual and i just didn't
click so i'm asking them like oh can i
have a refund you know i pay for these
lessons and they're like oh well no we
can't refund you but we can exchange
well that doesn't make sense like are
you gonna exchange it to someone else
who has different rates
i haven't even checked the messages i
just want to vent that out because um
yeah so i get denied refunds bro
i definitely get
uh that's interesting yeah and then if
you're you want to be that guy yeah if
you really want to be fair afterwards
calling amex being like excuse me
there's a company that i like to snitch
on i'm just playing bro yeah chargeback
is necessary at times i usually don't
like doing that because banks
basically flag you after a certain
amount of chargebacks that's why i've
never charged back bro anytime i have
a legitimate issue with like a merchant
or anything like that i try to let them
deal with it and if they don't then
try to press them again
but usually and there's just a tip guys
this is not finance episode but it's a
little thing on the side but
do things through paypal if you have the
opportunity because paypal customer
service and and client resolution center
on point if you have any disputes
anything like that this by the way it
sounds like a sponsor you know like i am
lucid does with some vpn thing
we're going to talk about people or not
this is generally a thing you can deal
with your your merchant if not you deal
with paypal rarely do you ever have to
go to the bank yeah i'll make my voice
deep for a second
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
but anyway back to the thing bro
the topic at hand there's genuinely
people with stuff with baggage with
business that they got to deal with
right
and we were actually talking about this
before the podcast um what do you say to
a lot of these people that you know
let's start with the people that first
of all don't even realize that they have
trauma from their childhood and how can
it affect them and and reflect on their
behavior today what's so funny bro i
don't want to say man
i don't want to say it
go on bro that was actually clean it was
very well put
why are your yeah so warm bro
hold on my hand again bro
my hands are real cold bro so every time
you grab my hand i just feel this
external warmth
[Music]
no i should have felt that
i was looking i thought i was trying
bro
bro that's that's um that's a good one
meant for me
am i just that that should be like the
only one that y'all play for me yeah i
agree a little gay fairy sound
what y'all need is the air horn
yeah yeah we're missing that
that was a question
people that have unresolved childhood
trauma right there's something we often
talk about how if it's unresolved right
as we said it can actually affect how
you think how you process emotions how
you deal with stuff how you handle
things
modern day in present day in your life
even if you're 20 30 40. so going on
that bro yeah so
i'm gonna do my best yeah i'm gonna be
honest with y'all my um
i just drank the full cup of coffee and
i really feel like my
my adhd is like
it's
it's activated bro
like my mind is racing my heart's
beating fast bro like i don't know why
these people even watch us
no but listen i'll do it
so
so uh
basically if someone has
er
if someone has a
if some listen if someone has
things wrong with them like from their
past the childhood
it's obviously gonna be very evident
in the way that they express themselves
and the way that they process emotions
and things like that and this is a very
clear indicator not just for
um someone
observing another person like if i was
observing rami
but if rami was just observing himself
like reflecting and just like looking
like his own actions and stuff like that
if you
let's say you snap a lot
or like someone says something and you
snap very easily
clear indicator that you've been through
something in your childhood right or
maybe someone says something and they
they just get very
i don't know just emotional like
triggered not even snapping like angry
but they just get like offended like sad
these are things like they're very clear
indicators
i really don't know where i'm going with
this to be honest with you no no you're
basically giving a list of things to
where people that most likely will
exhibit now if they have this unresolved
child well i hate to say this but uh
what was the question again
how can i get it dare you
none of that bro really how they can get
over this yeah bro like how like what
should they do about it how do they know
they have it in the first place so
you're giving something
okay yeah yeah see
does adhd fog your memory bro nah nah
i'm saying when i drink coffee like
sometimes it activates and like
my mind will be like 10 steps ahead but
also like 10 steps behind it's weird bro
so we talked about snapping not in
control of your angers what else
just emotional responses that are
unwarranted hmm like severe mood swings
it could be severe mood swings
um it could just be unable to process
certain things that are happening in
your day-to-day life
like let's say you had a business deal
that didn't go through but y'all were
like really wanting this business deal
to go through
and and i'm not even trying to like
relate to anything i'm just being like
genuine here like unless you have a
business deal let's say this was gonna
be it for you like this is gonna be what
you needed for you your family all this
stuff but it doesn't go through yeah
right and then like for you instead of
processing and be like damn you know
like that sucked like really reflected
on it and then just seeing like what
what you could learn from it how you can
move forward what you do now
is you grab your phone
and then you carry on to go on social
media for like an hour two hours
or you can carry on
you you could do that
kanye west ah hey i'm not saying no
names bro all right but let's say you
you go on to like
you let's say you go on netflix and you
start watching netflix for like hours
or you start
hanging out with um
your friends and family and just binge
binge eating as well like these are all
things where you're running away from
something that's happening now these are
clear indicators like
that at some point in your life you did
this
and it helped you
right why did it help you because when
you were a kid you don't know how to
handle things you don't know how to
process things
so but now we're we're grown so we
actually have the
the
facilities the capability the ability to
imbecility no no mohammed bro
that's what it is bro bro we have the
ability to to get over it now but as a
kid we didn't so as a kid you started
doing this thing it helped you um so now
you're just doing something that you
know deep down has helped you in the
past so these are clear indicators it's
almost like in psychology they call them
self-soothing behaviors
yeah you can see it like that but it's
like look if i'm seeing ramy exhibit
this and i really care for him i would
let him know thank you you know like or
if i saw it in myself then i would know
like i need to do something about it i
need a change
right and then from there again i'm
gonna ask you like what the question was
like what were we trying to refer this
to because there was a there was a big
point i know you're saying to get over
it but
for what
were we talking about i think i think
and over what let me how about this let
me let me kind of
teach you how mental we're talking about
mental health yeah mental but let me
kind of draw a framework of into like
why i'm asking this question right
um
long story short bro today
there's an overwhelming amount of people
that are normal thinking that they're
not normal yes facts there's probably no
other way or a better way i could put it
and there's not really a problem i know
what rami always says you know the
greatest problem you could have is not
knowing you have a problem but today we
have a lot of people thinking they have
a problem but there's actually no
problem it's probably just a nutritional
deficiency or a lack of sunlight or
exercise which we'll talk about always
at the end obviously but there are
people that think they have a problem
but it's it's just stuff they've been
through neurotic holding patterns or
unresolved trauma that they just haven't
coped with or processed properly so my
thing is you already talked about some
indicators you might be affected by it
right but let's say this person the sad
individual is watching and they're like
okay cool i might be one of them what do
they do about it do i seek therapy
should i get a diary should i go seek a
psychiatrist should i get on this
prescription medication what do you
think
so we're actually talking about this
we're literally going in yeah
um there's two ways that a person can go
about doing this
right first way
is
you know you reflect a lot
meditate you pray
and you do the inner work
what does that work the inner work is
like
basically being with the things that
come up so like let's say
you um realize okay i have an issue
what is this issue i don't know what the
issue is but i realize i got some kind
of issue right so you start sitting with
yourself you start reflecting on this
and like
as you reflect things are gonna start
coming up things that are very
uncomfortable maybe from each other
maybe repressed memories
and like that's the crazy thing is that
people have repressed memories and they
don't realize it until like
a certain sound
is made which triggers a memory a
certain smell maybe like a certain
sensation in their body or something
something triggers it and it's very
uncomfortable for them right so it's
like
when you start reflecting you start
seeing these things it's like
if you can stay with that kinda like
harambe said if if you're sad it's okay
to be sad just stay with it right if you
can stay with this this memory this
sensation that you're gonna be feeling
which is very uncomfortable then you can
effectively process that memory and go
further into
um i guess you could say the rabbit hole
whatever it is
the further you go the more inner work
you do
the more inner work you do
the more you heal and this sounds kind
of like
new haiti spiritually but it's it's real
like you you're basically processing
things and the more you process
the more capable you become as a human
being
i wanted to i wanted to add a point bro
do you know this guy named jason capital
he's an entrepreneur yeah he basically
has his cliche common popular term or
phrase it's what you resist persists and
he says that through all the clinical
research and psychiatric research
they've done anyone that has an emotion
come up which is very normal obviously
it makes us human but you try to resist
it let's say you're like really upset
and you're just like nah it actually
doesn't bother me i'm better than this
you know it's i'm beyond this you know
i'm not gonna let them stoop to their
level and you actually act like it
doesn't affect you it actually is going
to persist because you resisted it and
over time you're going to notice it's
going to reflect in how you treat your
spouse when you go home or some people
are stuck for love they take it out on
their pets you know or their kids and
this is the reality bro but what jason
capital was saying was if you feel let's
say anger right and you give yourself
this channeled professional safe
you know respectable and safe way to let
out this emotion and you really go into
it let's so let's say i'm angry like
three out of ten or like five out of ten
something happened to me someone cut me
off while i'm driving or something and
i'm i feel that emotion right but i
don't want to act like it doesn't bother
me so it'll persist so i find the way
let's say i like really go into that
anger right for example i'm like oh how
dare that guy you know cut me off and i
go into like eight out of ten nine out
of ten bro even though it wasn't it it
wasn't an eight out of ten it was
probably like a five out of ten but i
really go deep into it and what i
realized is a couple seconds later or a
couple minutes later it's actually gone
bro there's no more anger left in my
system but if i had resisted it it would
have persisted
right but you know i just thought about
this you know be like a very beneficial
and a very like lucrative business
you have a place where it's like people
go to specifically let out the anger and
you said about like a whole bunch of
things
let me let me let me bless you you're
here for a few more weeks maybe i'll
take you here there's this place i'm not
gonna name any mentions here because
obviously we're not getting paid
sponsors from this place so why would i
but there is a place in toronto right
it's you pay by the hour okay
you choose your weapon right so you can
either get a baseball bat or a big
sledgehammer or i don't know dummy might
know what i'm talking about or a big axe
or just huge weapons right you just
destroy it and you you pay by the size
of the room so the square foot is the
area of the room
and they have stuff like tvs
things that obviously people donated tvs
furniture electronics windows glass
bottles everything and your job is just
to have the process of mental catharsis
right because we're all emotionally
neutered today for some reason and you
just go off i think it's like 150 bucks
and you feel like yeah it's like a spot
that's like a little spot there bro
bro yeah but no i didn't come up with
that myself i've seen it that's why i
mentioned it but i think like that's
just a very lucrative and very
beneficial because like bro everyone has
anger and like
how often can we actually fully like
express it and like just release that
anger like the other day i was just
sitting on this couch over here that we
have in the other room and i was looking
at the table and i'm like you know i'm
not angry right now but like it would
feel really good to just pick it up and
like throw it across the room just
cathartic yeah just wanna start it you
know like
just release whatever happens
i didn't feel anything at that point now
imagine i did feel something like and
you have like oh here come come
just break break whatever you want but
i'm getting back to the topic getting
back to the topic right
um that's the first way the first way is
you do the inner work
yourself you reflect meditate pray
the second way
is uh i'd say the more easier
approach it doesn't take as much hard
work more mainstream approach you get a
therapist or you get someone that you
trust you talk to them
and basically this person is going to
act like your guide
they're going to
be the grounded force or the grounded
person while you talk and they're going
to kind of like
bring the the conclusions and solutions
for you or they're just going to suggest
things for you
that allow you to kind of make the
connections
you know and i don't want to be
a lot of people might say i'm sexist for
this but
um a lot of women tend to go the
the therapist route
a lot of men tend to do the
um in a work route
um but that's not to say that a woman
can't do it in a work route nor to say
that a man can't go to a therapist you
know yeah i'm just saying like from what
i've seen this is just
so therapeutic therapy works then it's
not one of those cliches like i hear a
lot of people in in like the manosphere
they talk about you know marriage
counseling not working and they have you
know studies to prove this that you know
marriage counseling is not as effective
as other factors are but
therapy individual therapy yeah that's
different it's different than marriage
counseling okay
so therapy is it just going to someone
like a licensed therapist or can you do
it with your homeboy can you like what
is it how do you do it bro cause a lot
of people don't have a listening ear
so with a therapist they're coming from
uh
they're coming from a non-emotional
place most of the time like
if you tell your boy like they might get
emotional for you what do you mean oh
okay maybe you're going through
something then you come to me and you
tell me about it and i'm just like yo
are you serious bro are you serious like
you're going to let this person do this
you know you're going to let yourself go
through something like this
bro like i'm over here getting emotional
for you and then it clouds like it's my
judgment the answer and like just the
whole healing process right versus the
therapist that could just kind of like
they might ask you
so it's an external party
yeah okay well okay when when you
self-reflect
what do you do you're asking yourself oh
why do i feel this
right like when romney was experiencing
what he was experiencing did you ask
yourself like oh why do i why do i feel
like this i also ask myself why am i
thinking of these things yeah why can't
i get rid of these thoughts
and then you started to come to
different answers different conclusions
right you started going deeper yeah so
basically the therapist is doing what
you will be doing in that situation
asking those questions to allow you
the
thera it would be therapy therapy
the person receiving the therapy the
patient the patient
come on bro
uh sometimes we get a little too caught
up in the sauce like a little warmth bro
thanks bro
say martial
about it bro this is a no hazard zone by
the way but anyone watching um i do want
to kind of
reiterate this point a little more here
guys
it's happening at this point bro there
we go
i did resume on this
one
but yeah it's a legit thing bro like
therapy but i do want to i do want to
ask you this all right
a lot of people they
might not have the money
to invest in therapy
um
and they might think is it really
necessary is it really not and let me
ask a better question how about that a
lot of people might not see the benefits
of therapy as that valuable
and they might think okay why don't i
invest in something else why don't i do
this or that the reality is a lot of
this stuff that brodano was talking
about like the inner work or or going to
a therapy and then resolving this this
inner childhood conflict or whatever
trauma
if you don't do it it's actually going
to affect you and hinder you in life in
ways that you might not have thought
possible such as giving you anxiety it
could be actually the root of a lot of
anxiety depression a lot of ocd a lot of
tourette's a lot of
modern day
symptoms
psychologically and people might think
oh it's just because of this or that bro
it could actually just be linked from
something that happened as a kid bro
i mean thinking about this right
you want to work out
you want to build muscle yes
can you do it yourself
yeah yeah yeah now what if you have a
friend or you have a personal trainer
and they know everything
you can go to them yeah and they would
effectively help you to get from point a
to point b
like that much quicker yeah than if you
were to just do it by yourself right
so with this
it's um
[Music]
it's essentially
i wouldn't say it's the same but think
about it like this right someone who
doesn't see the value in
therapy
it's because they haven't done any inner
work themselves because i used to be in
that boat where i was like i used to see
therapists and be like
people really pay money for this
yeah you know but then after i did like
the self work myself i realized
damn this is tough
this is really tough and sometimes like
i don't want to do it
so like my journey
it may look like this it's like it'll
it'll go up then it'll it'll just
freeze maybe it might even go down then
it might go up again with a therapist
it's it might not be as fast but there's
consistent growth mm-hmm why because
he's the one or she's the one that's
actually
you know
yeah they're guiding you through it so
um
it's
again it's not exactly the same example
but it's to say that you know like there
is benefit in the therapy
and um if you feel like you really just
can't do it yourself
you can get someone else and they would
allow you to grow even faster um yeah i
want to jump in here please bro please
so um
[Music]
um we have islam right
now i i heard once there was actually a
little like presentation that was done
for us in back in high school and the
lady
the one thing i remember from the
presentation is she showed this little
triangle each corner had different
things thoughts feelings and actions and
she taught us that thoughts feelings and
actions work in a triangle
if you change
what you do you change your actions you
will change your thoughts and your
feelings you change your thoughts you'll
feel you'll change your feelings and
actions right if you somehow change your
feelings you'll change your thoughts and
actions as well right like if you start
thinking that i should be more grateful
and start thinking about the things to
be grateful for to allah which we are
encouraged to do
you will feel that gratitude you will
feel happier you will feel more grateful
to allah and you may be more giving as
well likewise if you go out to a
homeless person you just give them five
dollars right that action seeing
you know their response and so on and so
forth sometimes they have a good
response to allah you will think and
feel better as well um and the reality
is i think there's a lot of habits that
people have that
feed into this
depressing lifestyle that they're living
in the depressing thoughts that they
have um not everyone obviously right
and i always encourage people to see
professional insha'allah if you need
help no shame so you can help from
professional but for i'd say a lot of
people
who what kind of look like what you
mentioned they make a problem that they
don't have or something like that
right either you have a problem where
you're making money right if you think
that either you have
and what people realize is a lot of the
time the habits that they feed into
every single day is is fueling this kind
of sad life that they have um
and i had a really good point now it's
in my head
but i think we can definitely bring it
closer at the end i do want to go deeper
into points and also some other stuff
that we can give as home remedies or
lifestyle changes and stuff like that
and shout like
um and stuff like that inshallah um
actually you know what i will say this
before we go on
guys
a lot of the issues that people have
mentally
psychologically especially in couples
is just usually a lack of intimacy
this is just something that you know i
don't normally i know you you're
blushing bro but listen
when it comes to communication when it
comes to
congruency
trust translation there's a lot of
elements that are important in a
relationship right
but i do think a lack of intimacy leads
to more problems than people think that
it does and it can also solve
a lot of problems if
repairing it so inshallah we'll go into
that little deeper with a very special
guest we have in a couple weeks
insha'allah very soon you guys will see
inshallah
aside from that going right back in uh
okay cool let's say they do the inner
work or they take the second means which
is going to be getting a therapist or a
licensed counselor or just someone to
hear them bro someone they can venture
let's say they do this now aside from
this they do have general things that
they're doing day to day that might make
their symptoms worse
do you want to talk about some of these
before we go into the lifestyle changes
that we can do to fix this inshallah
i can get one
i was to act like that
like that i wonder like
well what do you think the answer is to
that question
um i don't know that's why i'm asking
you
i can't if we can't even do it wrong
no the guy on that was oh first off yeah
what do you think
like legit that's why i'm saying legit
okay generally one of the things that
i'll say is uh that's a long sound board
bro hold on for like 15 seconds
one legit thing that i can think of
that's contributing to most people's
mental symptoms is
processed
foods
and
drinks
yes this is the unsexy answer because
everyone's just looking for it
yes subhanallah by the way i just want
to give no shout out though they're not
sponsoring us but i don't know why you
looking at them
isn't mine
[Music]
but that's the reality bro processed
foods
processed drinks they include a lot of
chemicals that are not bioavailable
they're not easy to produce at all but
okay
that works
okay i remember i was gonna say right i
was talking about we could have habits
every day that could feed this kind of
negative way of thinking and and the sad
thoughts and the feelings and all that
stuff
but what if i told you the inverse is
also true you could have positive habits
that feed into a positive lifestyle a
positive mentality a positive way of
thinking and thoughts feelings and
actions
you know i would say there's an
overarching
category of of perspective right how do
you view these thoughts feelings and
actions because as someone who doesn't
have religion you eventually fall into
some kind of moral nihilism unless you
don't think about it at all if you think
about it eventually you're like well
god you this is a morally nihilistic
person god doesn't exist
we are here by random chance
we came from nothing nothing is
objectively morally right nothing's
objectively morally wrong
nothing matters i'm going to die and
it's not going to matter my loved ones
are going to die it's not going to
matter that's very nihilistic that's
that's depressing
for our muslims we know allah exists we
know islam is true we know that there's
a life after death right that's what
allah says that he created life
he created death and life to test who
was good indeed or best indeed so on and
so forth so we can frame our thoughts
feelings and actions with that
perspective so now even your suffering
becomes something that is actually in a
way positive because allah and allah uh
but the prophet
there is a beautiful hadith which is
very known to everyone but i do want to
reiterate it because it's very important
he said amazing is a state of a believer
because
if something good happens to them if
something you know nice
joyful hair something good happens to
them
they're grateful and that's better for
them and if something difficult happens
to them if a calamity strikes them
they're patient and that's better for
them
because we are rewarded by allah even
for enduring some kind of difficulty
physically mentally or otherwise so it's
very beautiful when a muslim frames
their life based off of this even
depressing sad things could actually be
very beautiful even death is you know
seen as kind of the the the first step
towards jannah inshallah after you know
after your life
so
[Music]
but without going too much into details
guys
i do want to talk about a little bit
about
some of the things they can do for
lifestyle changes for diet that type of
stuff just some generic stuff you know
not not too much go into the details but
just give them like a little layman's
guide to
you know having good mental don't do
them like you did in the last ep
do what
or you're like oh let's just keep it
simple for them all right so with the
calorie a calorie is basically your unit
of energy
listen listen bro listen listen we're
not gonna go that deep
shadow
quick first thing i'm going to say is
the diet aspect that i'm passing to you
um if you guys can avoid
processed foods refined sugars refined
carbohydrates um a lot of the stuff we
talked about in the nutrition stuff you
will notice a huge benefit inshallah
into how
stable your mental health is
and the reason i will say this is
because when you have a lot of these
processed foods you get a lot of energy
right away so you get a huge peak
and then when it kind of burns off you
get a little dip and then you condition
your mind to be okay with these peaks
and dips and you are in a turbulent
state of mind however if you're having
real food whole foods it's more mellow
more plateau
like think of when you're fasting you
know it's very consistent right so i'm
gonna end it with that bro yeah like
think about
thinking about the foods that
uh make you feel good even after
so like your dates and honey yeah well
dates and honey mm-hmm if you just eat
dates and honey i don't know you might
have a little
you might be a little wide and have a
little crash after
a lot of sugar
but
it could be something like this like the
coffee like y'all saw how ridiculous i
was
a few minutes ago in the beginning of
the podcast i asked the same question
like four or five times
so i was like that that in and of itself
you know that's like you got to pay
attention to things that you eat consume
like is it to say never drink coffee or
never have something like this no i'm
more to say like look you just eat in a
way
which is more beneficial
right and then you can
you can eat these other things and drink
these other things
at other times you know uh
responsibly
responsibly inshallah what what other
things would you say wrong because you
know
anything just just big themes in
lifestyle that they got to change yeah
you mentioned that they could have
things that are
making it hard or not harder but it's
like bring them
uh more distress but then they could
have habits that are actually bringing
them yeah more benefit so in your in
your eyes yeah um i thought you asked
about diet that's why no no anything
else like saliva i showed my main areas
in my coffee
too many things
but yeah um i i after this insha'allah
after my points your points and we end
off i think we should give a little
step-by-step sure what people should do
if they are under success because a lot
of people are unfortunately so what i
would say
is something that's more practical
because what i said was general i want
to give something a little more
practical is to practice being grateful
to allah everyone has problems i'm not
saying therefore we should be grateful
right but it could be so much worse
there are people who have problems
so
significantly life-changing
you know morale damaging
that if you were in their shoes for half
a day you would have offered yourself
not even joking
all right there are people there are
young kids in palestine who lost both
their parents because one
disgusting dog of a man with a gun
literally are there parents who have
lost all their children because that
same dog of a man with a gun this
state's not doing anything about it the
so-called superpowers amazing super
powers of the west are not doing
anything about it actually feeding into
it and encouraging it you know imagine
living that kind of life you know and
allah is going to reward these people
insha'allah extremely extremely well i
mean allah reward the muslim suffering i
mean but it goes to show that listen
you're living in a relatively safe
neighborhood country
a relatively wealthy family or good
enough you're not starving every single
night right you have access to all these
things that you know
the vast majority of human beings on the
earth don't have access to you know if
you just took
five seconds
to sit down and remember this and thank
allah for it that would drastically
improve your mentality towards life
towards helping other people towards
yourself
and
i also want to add
as another note don't be so hard on
yourself i have a horrible habit
of of completely hating like i feel like
some i used to sometimes be my biggest
enemy
like negative self-talk yeah like i do
one thing wrong and i just
like there's something my fiancee told
me a lot about that i used to do to
myself like to do one thing wrong and i
like go like self-destruct mode like i i
like hate me i'm so angry at myself and
hate myself and it could be something so
small
and alhamdulillah i've grown a lot from
it but if i you know if she didn't point
that out to me if i didn't realize it
then i never would have fixed it and
that is something that's so damaging
people who they're just way too hard on
them like they're very lenient with
other people when it comes to themselves
for some reason they expect this kind of
perfection and again that ties into the
whole i'm sad but i shouldn't be feeling
sad kind of thing right
you're going to mess up you should mess
up if you don't mess up something's
wrong with you you're not a human being
right maybe a robot or something carry
it created by apple or elon musk right
maybe you're one of those ai and there's
really advanced all of a sudden right
but on a real note if you're not how
dare you
if you're not messing up
then you're not normal right you should
be messing up it's normal now if you're
not sad then you're not normal you
should be sad once in a while so on and
so forth i think putting in that
perspective is really helpful um
i don't know anything else i got one
i feel like i go through that to be
honest
yeah but what was specifically what you
just said
well i'm very strict with myself yeah
yeah and i'm still learning bro like
i can't say that i'm like fully passive
but
like i'm very strict with myself and
then anytime that i like mess up or
something
i like i'd
demonize myself but i put myself down
and like self-sabotage myself like bro
you you've seen it you even mentioned it
i was like damn but i i didn't i don't
usually tell people that but here i am
telling
all of you guys
oops
but
aside from that i do have another point
that i want to talk about before we
carry on uh this is an easy lifestyle
change that i got from my boy
but it's a very effective one
nonetheless it's movement and exercise
um if you haven't watched the other
episode um from last week on fitness and
and just
being active bro living an active
healthy lifestyle getting away from the
sedentary lifestyle it really goes a
long way and to connect that to if you
can combine it with being outside
because it leads to my next point of sun
exposure just getting sunlight i think
vitamin d nutritional deficiencies not
being in the sun leads to a lot of these
issues bro so you want to combine it why
don't you do some physical activity
outside you know go for a walk go for a
run it doesn't have to go play
basketball it doesn't have to be
anything crazy you know just be out in
nature and inshallah a lot of these
problems will go away bro yeah
yeah
yeah
that kind of
smell kind of touches another point
that's popped in my head you know i went
through i i tried to get married once
right and i went downhill and i told the
story too many times or did we know yeah
i i was it really put me in a bad state
that's something i remember doing i
mentioned it once or twice i made a list
of my goals and i put it as my screen
saver on my phone so every time on my
phone i see it and i
had a number of goals right i mentioned
this before like learn islam and give a
dawah and work out and grow my hair out
and all this stuff right and you guys
saw i had longer hair for some time and
all that stuff
um
having something to work towards is is
very very important especially for men
because men we're more like we need to
like
men a lot of time when there's a problem
they want to fix it and i find myself
like you saw how i was last night when
that thing i'm like i want to do this
now
right i want to do this right now that's
how i am that's how i think men are but
they probably want to deal with it
physically they want to work on it right
so it's really important to have some
kind of goal in life especially if you
are sad or upset which i think maybe i
should have started off with this that
you know where grief or where you know
depression and sadness come from because
it's either you lost something that
you're grieving or you're fearing
something in the future that's mainly
where it comes from either you feel you
should have something that you don't or
you lost something that you had and that
gives you this kind of sadness this void
in your heart um
a lot of times
you know if it's something like you
you know you
i don't know i don't want to say but
maybe you feel like you should be more
successful or maybe you feel like you
should be more comfortable in life or
something now set that as a goal and
work towards obviously you have some
prospective issues if you feel like you
need this or deserve that because nobody
does or to be honest but having these
goals and working towards something
bigger is and for me it's helped me a
lot when i had no goals and i was just
kind of like screwing around playing
video games whatever that was honestly
some of the worst
points in my life
um i do want to mention a point to to
add to that is if you guys can avoid and
try to avoid and by the way this is not
medical advice this is not we're not
licensed medical practitioners
whatsoever but just avoiding unnecessary
medications
okay this is a huge one
um this is not to say if you have
prescribed you've been prescribed
antidepressants or benzos or anything by
your psychiatrist no i'm not saying
don't take them you know follow the you
know consult the medical uh you know
advisor before anything but unnecessary
stuff you know you take too many
tylenols or advils or too many of these
these pills or that pills and you just
popping pills left and right
anti-inflammatories you know painkillers
all of this stuff
these are all to some greater or lesser
extent endocrine disruptors they mess up
your hormones and they will mess up your
mental health and your emotions and
everything like that so just rule of
thumb just avoid anything that you can
avoid right again not medical advice but
if you
open your eyes and do some research
you'll realize a lot of these things can
be solved with real things in your diet
specific types of herbs or seeds and you
really don't need these
drugs like you think you do
i think the final point to end it off
is
make time
make time for yourself
and uh whatever you're going through
i'm sure because if you don't make time
for it
oh it's gonna make time for you
it's gonna control you from the behind
the scenes the background
so might as well make time for it might
as well
um process a heal from it because
just imagine what your life could be
if you didn't have these things
affecting you
from behind the scenes
i actually made a video today about this
aside from the t3 empty i was like
in you know recording for my own channel
and uh one of the biggest things that i
was mentioning was actually three habits
so it's a little plug this video that i
don't know it might be out
before this song i don't know but um one
of the things was uh really taking that
time out to self-reflect
and i was saying that like
if you look at who you are now
and then you look at who you were maybe
like let's say
like five ten years ago
you're actually still the same person
like the only biggest difference is like
you may have learned a little bit more
you may have gotten a little bit wiser
physically you may have grown as well
um but like who you are like at your
core is still the same like
maybe you picked up on some little
traits maybe like some little maybe you
grew a beard you got your voice deeper
no
the thing is we are a product of our
environment yeah yeah so like if if i'm
hanging around you and like you do a
certain thing and like bro we're really
close i'll probably pick up on that and
i'll start doing that thing as well but
to your core you're still you exactly
that's what i'm trying to say is that
like five ten years
later you're still the same you just
picked up on a few key things here and
there but like who you are has already
been set
by allah by the creator
so it's like
what i'm trying to get at here there was
a definitely a good point that i was
trying to get at man
oh that's a lot brothers eight chirps i
didn't even know that subhanallah um
guys give your hands bro
go to you moment of silence right now
for uh
brother angela who can't think of uh
what he wanted to say
inshallah you can in the future
i don't remember what i was talking
about no worries so this one like
basically what you're saying is
um for a lot of these people right
they're uh
your brain bro we can just cut it off
like when i said just make time for
yourself and stuff like we can cut off
from there you could you would you think
that the the the creators already and in
a way programmed who you are gonna be
right
at your core
and you pick up on all these things as
you grow older maybe you were gonna go
say that you can unlearn these things or
what nah i don't
truly remember everything i was gonna
say but i guess what i can say is like
who you are is pretty damn great
you just have to you know chill out and
remove all the uh
the bad traits or
the um the bad traumas that we've had
in our childhood like if you remove
these things like you're just unveiling
who you are and who you are it was
already
decreed way before you came into this
world so
um that's again that's not what i was
going to say but it's not a good bro
it happens
i don't know more coffee bro no more
coffee for you bro
rami you mentioned at the end you want
to leave them with a step-by-step plan
yeah something like that yeah let's do
it inshallah and then we'll wrap it up
all right
so
first and foremost know that it's very
human to feel what you're feeling right
um you wouldn't be human if you didn't
feel this way um feeling upset is normal
just know that allah has created you
with the capabilities to grow to become
better to become stronger and allah says
in the quran
regime
that
allah does not burden us all beyond that
which you can take meaning that if allah
has put you in a place where xyz has
happened to you and you're upset about
it
believe it or not i know it feels like
it's crippling like it's crushing allah
actually has not given you more than you
can handle he's given you what he knows
you can handle and he's rewarding you
for every step that you go through this
with saber with patience and with
gratitude towards allah i don't want to
get too deep into gratitude and patience
and all that stuff and what i imagine
allah said about it but it's very deep
and beautiful if you want to look into
that
so first is perspective how you view the
hardship and all that your relationship
with allah you knowing that your
destination is supposed to be jannah
insha allah may allah grant us
and that this world is just something
that's temporary that's passing by very
very quickly right i like that little
thing i know if they can see it the
little hour glass we have up there
because it reminds me bring it down bro
that's running out right and that's
exactly what i think about it can you
recite surah sir i think i think with
arnold schwarzenegger no you want to say
yeah yeah
guys come on hell if if if if angel
recites this then we got to get you know
2 000 likes on this video inshallah
let's go bismillah i don't want to you
actually do it beautifully bro
but are you are you saying only we get
to hear it while we pray in celebrities
i only like reciting like in person or
not on the spot
i feel you
how about a quick translation from
either of you i wanna i honestly i asked
you to reset it because the eurostation
of al-assad is much better than mine i
think it's really good bro the reason i
say this is every time you we pray you
always do surah allah first after fatiha
and then you do something like surah
class after and bro trust me i get super
captivated in the first one and me
personally i'm not just saying this to
hype you up but i don't want the viewers
to like not get this bro because it's
such an iman booster here appreciate it
bro come on and just
don't don't feel right to just
no force bro yeah
yeah another time
inshallah inshallah
all right guys hashtag shy boy if you
guys made this right now i'm just
playing we should have a zombie it's
like
no no this is haram
[Music]
he swears by time all right
and and also there's time that's running
out in the
indeed mankind is in loss right they're
in lost
it's very powerful if you think about it
right all of mankind is in love not the
believers not the disability we're
getting everyone yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then allah says
except those who believe
and those who do good deeds
and those who remind to uh to the truth
well to us
those who remind patients and obviously
have patience themselves by allah so you
will be in loss unless you
call to good believe do good right call
to the truth and call for you and others
to have patience that is the perspective
you should have in sha allah actually
some people say i don't know if it's the
habit of the scholars um but they say
that
you said it
that if if all allah revealed
then it would have
the mentality that we should have when
it comes to it also
is very beautiful for him it was
revealed in the process of assad and
look into that to look into the islamic
remedies that we have inshallah they're
very beautiful videos on that very very
touching videos actually next is the
daily habits that you can change in your
life today right it could be negative
self-talk like me and angel talked about
could be your diet like brother fry
talked about could be a number of things
that you find yourself doing to either
feed the issue that you have the the
depression the sadness or to try and
escape the depression sadness that you
have you need to make time out to
yourself dedicate time to yourself be
comfortable with sitting with yourself
and be able to really express to
yourself and understand what you're
feeling why you're feeling it and
reflect on things and you're going to
find things come out that you might be
uncomfortable with but that discomfort
is good because no one on the face of
the earth and this is even you can um i
don't want to say it's a sudden of allah
you know just to protect myself may
allah forgive us but it's it's almost
like a sunnah for a human being where
they will not grow unless they're in
something that's uncomfortable right
even allah the the second and third
times angel jibril came to the process
he said oh you who's wrapped up oh you
who's covered you who's sitting in a
state of of trying to comfort himself
right so he said him get up and warn get
up and go warn and then after that
i believe is the third revelation to
come not only get up and warn us get up
and warn and then stand up for a long
portion of the night or a portion of the
night in prayer right he's like you
who's comfortable who's covered who's
you know cozy right now get up and go
warn
allah because you're not gonna grow
unless you're in an uncomfortable state
and it's uncomfortable to sit with
yourself and think about why you feel
depressed and that stuff but it needs to
be done if you can't do it yourself go
see a professional there's no shame in
that understand that that growth is not
linear it's not it's never a straight
line up you're going to stagnate you're
going to fall back like angel was saying
and uh
the whole point is that the roi the like
the return on that investment in
yourself goes up over time and right you
might you know go from here to up here
and then back down here but eventually
you're gonna keep moving up and down up
and down until you reach a point in sha
allah where you're in a better state
i think those are my steps you guys
should add
which sahaba was it i believe it was
but you can correct me bro um he said
that allah tests the those he loves the
most
i don't know
i don't know i don't know
the hadith
no but just know regardless of the
validity of that or not allah writes in
the quran allah says in the quran that
you know do they think they will say
that they believe and they won't be
tested yeah i think it's
but you know
the main message that i'm trying to say
is it's not supposed to be easy right
just like brother ramirez has been
saying it's not supposed to be easy
we've been sold this this fairy tale
that it's supposed to be easy and we
sympathize because bro i can speak for
myself and i'm sure the other two
brothers can speak for themselves
respectively that we all go through the
exact same stuff that y'all go through
if not probably even worse at times so
trust me we we're all in this together
we all go through the exact same stuff
together by the end of the day
understand that the prophet saws
mentioned that holding on to your deen
of islam is going to be like holding on
to hot cold there will come a time and
today it's more pivotal than ever that
we remember these steps keep ourselves
sane in check and mentally healthy so
that we can do what we were here
and purposed to do inshallah
i mean
i mean
and um
i think these two brothers said
everything perfectly don't think there's
anything else i had on you gotta
research for the lesser bro that's all
you got to do not a second play nah it's
it's an eagle thing like i know my ego
and like i don't like receiving praise
or anything like that so you just start
to let it go forward marshall bro no
that's a good name it's like any time
that someone praises me for it it's like
i know how my ego is and
over time like my ego will start to get
big off of it that's why i'm very
hesitant with um
[Music]
like learning too much and then
saying all this stuff that i learned
because
people were like oh wow and then it's
like to me like
my ego bro i just know how my ego works
and i'm not trying to fall down that
ragged hole bro
[Music]
i'm the romantic if y'all if y'all are
with me y'all will hear it hello but if
y'all not with me he probably won't hit
they didn't make this far bro in that
case yeah yeah
but that being said that's everything we
have for you guys today
go ahead
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hello
[Music]